hi i'm beau carnes with freecodecamp in
this tutorial that you're watching right
now
i'm going to show you how to create a
discord bot with python
that runs completely in the cloud you
don't need to install anything on your
computer
and you don't need to pay anything to
host your bot we're going to use a
number of tools
including the discord api some python
libraries
and a cloud computing platform called
replit
you probably already know what discord
is and what a discord bot is since you
are watching this tutorial
but just in case you don't let me give
you a brief overview
discord is an app used for real-time
text chat
discord servers are set up by people and
generally are focused on a certain
community
many groups and organizations have
discord servers for people to chat with
each other
a discord server often has many channels
which are different rooms you can chat
in
a discord bot is a user in your discord
server
that is controlled by a program instead
of a person
you can code a discord bot to make it do
whatever you want
there are many things discord bots are
often used for they can be used to chat
respond to messages manage servers play
music
and more you can also use webhooks with
a discord bot
to do things like give real-time updates
on a github repository
the first step for creating a discord
bot is to make sure you have a discord
server to add the bot to
you may already have one but let me just
show you how to set one up really quick
in case you don't already have one
so you're going to have to go to
discord.com and log into discord
and then you just click the plus button
here to add a server
and i'll say for me and my friends and
i'll just call it
robot family server
okay let's create that and now
we have our server okay so before we can
code our bot using python and using the
discord api
we must first create a discord bot
account
right within discord so you're going to
have to go to the discord
developer portal i'll put the link in
the description
but it's just discord.com slash
developers
slash applications so once you're on the
applications page
you're going to click this new
applications button
and then we're going to create a name
for it this bot
is going to send friendly encouragements
to people from
in discord so i'm going to call it
encourage
bot okay
i'll create that okay now i'm going to
go to the bot tab here
and then i am going to click add
bot and say yes
do it okay we'll keep the dis
the default settings as a public bot
and then we won't require the oauth to
grant the code grant
so now the the bot has been created
the next step is to copy the bot token
okay so i'll just click copy to copy the
token
we're gonna need that later now this
token is your bot's password
so make sure not to share with anybody
it could allow someone to log into your
bot and do
all sorts of bad things and it could
even allow someone to
mess with your server and also you can
obviously regenerate the token if it
accidentally gets shared
so now we have to invite the bot to our
server
we have the bot user and we have to get
it into our server
to do that we're going to have to create
an invite url for it
so let's go to the oauth 2 tab here
and now we're just going to go to the
scope section since this is a bot
we'll just click bot here now we have to
scroll down a little bit more
and go to the bot permissions section
so we'll choose the the permissions we
want for the bot
our bot is going to be mainly used for
text messages
so we don't need a lot of permissions so
your bot may do different things but
let's just uh
choose some of these here actually we'll
do all of them on this line
except send tts messages now you do need
to be
careful with this administrator
permissions
if you give your bot administrator
permissions it has a it will
be able to control your server in ways
that you may not actually want
and then i guess the last one we need to
add is the view channels our bots gonna
have to view the channels
so after selecting the appropriate
permissions
we'll click the copy button right here
and this will copy a
url that can be used to add the bot to a
server
and i guess we'll also have to recopy
the bot key we copied the bot key
earlier but now it's been recopied with
this url so we'll have to come back
later to get the bot key
but now let's just open up a new tab and
i'm going to go to this url
okay so now we have to choose the server
we want to add the bot to i'll
choose robot family server the only
option
but you will probably have more than
more options so we'll click continue
and we want to approve that we want to
do all these things we're going to
authorize the bot
for all these things
and i'm not a robot and the bot is
authorized
that means the bot has joined the server
so if we actually go over
into our server we can see encourage bot
just slid into the server but also you
see over here that the bot is offline
it's not going to be online until we
write our python code
that creates the bot and run the python
code
and speaking of python code it's time to
start that
now i said earlier that you don't have
to install anything you don't have to
use any
software except your web browser we are
going to be creating
the entire discord bot right in the
cloud
on replit the website for replit
is repl.it and
replit is an online ide that you can
just use in your web browser
so it makes it a lot easier to code
things if you don't have to install any
special software on your computer
and then you can log into it from
multiple browsers multiple computers and
then you can
easily access your code in your programs
no matter what computer you're using
so we're going to make our on this and
then we'll also be completely
hosted in the cloud we can even run the
bot
on on this website so we don't have to
run it on our local computer
and that will make it so we can keep the
bot running
even if our computer shuts down or what
we're gonna where we close the browser
tab or anything like that
i'll show you how to make the bot so
it'll keep running in the background
uh continuously and then you don't have
to worry about it
if you don't already have account you're
gonna sign up but i'm going to log in
here
okay now that i'm logged in i'm going to
click this new reply in the corner here
now we just have to create choose the
language that we're going to use
for this new rebel the cool thing about
replit
is that you can use a bunch of different
languages with it
and so that makes it simple like if
you're going to run some of these
languages on your computer
you probably are going to have to
install some extra software
or extra things on your computer to be
able to run these languages but if you
just go to replit you can just do it
right in your browser and you don't have
to install
anything but we're going to be doing
this in python so i'll click python
and it will have a default name here but
i'm just going to be calling it
encourage bot
okay and i'll just create the rebel
so let's go over the main parts of
replit
we have here which is right here is the
code editor
and you can see it defaults with a a
file open called main.pi and we can type
our python code right in here
and then here over here are the files
and you can create new files
we will be creating a few new files in
the course of creating the spot
you can also create new folders and then
over here is the console
the console is where the standard output
will appear
and you'll be prompted to enter input if
you're gonna have input in your code
and in python it's gonna it's gonna
double as an interactive prompt
so you can actually type in python code
right here
and it will evaluate the code
interactively
so that's pretty cool and then over here
we have some things on the side here
so files version control if you're going
to associate with
git and or we're not going to do that in
this tutorial though
and then if you're going to install
packages but there's also another way to
install patches that we'll see
and then the main thing we're actually
going to be using is the
replic database so one thing cool about
repli is it includes a database
as part of it and so you can easily
store
things that will keep stored in there
even if you stop your program and run it
again
the everything store in the database
will will still be in there
so we will be using that later in this
tutorial
and then you can also change some
settings um just like the theme
font size all sorts of stuff like that
but let's go back
to the files because we're going to
start
creating our discord bot right now so i
mentioned that we're going to be using
the discord.pi library
and the first thing we're going to do is
import that library so at the top i'll
just do
import discord
and the cool thing here is that in
replit it will automatically install
this dependency when you press the run
button
so i mean my program doesn't do very
much right now but if i click run
we'll see on the side here that it's
installing the discord
dependency and then it will be able to
use it in the program
right away so there's nothing extra you
have to do to install dependencies
besides just
importing them right in your program so
let me talk a little bit about
discord.pie before we continue with
this spot here it revolves around the
concept of events
an event is something you listen to and
then respond to
for example when a message happens in
discord you will receive an
event about it that you can respond to
it
so let's make a bot that replies to a
specific message
we're going to start with a very simple
bot
and then we're going to add to it and
just add more features as we go
so this simple bot that we're going to
start with the code is actually
taken directly from the discord.pi
documentation
it's a really good example of like the
most basic bot you can make
and like i said then we'll continue to
build on that after we get this simple
created okay so we got the
discord library imported so let's add
some more lines here
so now we are going to create instance
of a client
this is the connection to discord so do
client
equals discord dot client
this is just part of the discord.pi
library
now we are going to use the client.event
decorator to register an event
that looks like this
so i remember i mentioned that this
client uses events
to make it work so this is how you
register an event
and this is an asynchronous library
discord.pi
so things are done with callbacks a
callback is a function that is called
when something else happens
so in this code we are going to use the
on ready event so i'm going to put async
def on ready
so this event is going to be called when
the bot is ready to start
being used and
when it's start when it's ready when the
bot is ready we're going to do this
print and this is going to print right
to this console right here
so when the bot is run and ready to be
used
it's going to print this to the console
it's going to say
we have logged in
as and then we're going to actually be
able to get the username that's logged
in as
and this is how you do that
so there's a few ways to do it but so
this is taking the client
this xero is being replaced with the
client so it's
doing the client.user so that's this
client this zero gets replaced with this
client here
and it's client.user to get the username
and i just have to make sure i have this
set actually the quote goes here
and there we go
okay let's create another event so
that's the event that happens as soon as
the bot is ready
and it's working so the next event is if
it receives a message if the bot senses
a message right in the discord server
so it's going to start off just the same
to register the event
and we're going to do another async
function
but this one is on message
so these function names are specifically
from the discord.pi library it's looking
for these function names
to know what to do when certain things
happen
this on message event triggers each time
a message is received
but we don't want to do anything if the
message is from ourselves which is the
bot
if the message is from the bot we want
to do nothing and this events
takes an argument called message or you
can
call anything you want but it's
traditional to call it a message because
it's the message that's being received
so this event triggers each time a
message is received but we don't want it
to do anything
if the message is from ourselves we're
gonna make it
check if the message is from ourselves
so if message dot author
equals client dot user looks like i
spelled something wrong there
so if the author of the message is the
user our bot user
all we're going to do is return the next
thing we're going to do is we're going
to see if the message starts with a
command that's being sent to our discord
bot
and we can make up those commands to be
anything we want
so in this case i'll show you what we're
going to do if dot message.content
dot starts starts
with and we're just going to make it up
to be dollar sign
hello for our bot we're gonna say
all the commands are messages that start
with the dollar sign
so if the message starts with dollar
sign hello
then the bot should know that it's
received a command so it should return
something and to return a message back
to discord
we're gonna do await
message dot channel dot
send so this is going to send a message
to the channel
and the message is going to be hello
okay so now so whenever the bot
notices that someone says dollar sign
hello within discord it's going to
respond
hello with an exclamation point so this
is everything we need for the bot but we
still have to
run the bot so here's the line to run
the bot
client
dot run and then right in the client.run
we need to put our
token we need to put our bots
token which is like the password for the
bot before we just
um go and copy the token again and put
it right in here
there's something i should tell you
about replit that you need to be careful
with
by default all replits are
public they're visible to anyone so
anyone can just
access your replit and they could
potentially see anything
you put in your replit including any
secrets or
keys and remember i told you that this
key is like a password you don't want
anybody else to find out about it
but there is a way to keep things secret
and that is to use an environment
variable
so in replica let me show you how you
can use
environment variables we are going to
first of all create a new file here
and the new file is going to be called
dot env
so the anything we put in a dot env file
will not be made public nobody will be
able to see
anything in a env file uh in reply
pretty much on a public account on a
free tier account
everything is public always except just
this one file.env
we're going to put token equals and
we're going to set the token to equal
our token now we're gonna have to go
back and get our token so let's go back
to our
um development portal page the
discord.com
developers and then i'm gonna go to bot
i'm gonna copy the token and then we
will
go back over here okay
there's my token um i'm gonna disable
this spot later and change the token so
don't bother trying to figure it out to
use it for your own
code but now that we have our token we
have to make it so it gets into
our main file so to do that
we are going to have to do and have
another import statement here so i'm
going to put
import os and then down here
we need to access that token from the
emv file so what we're going to put in
our code here
is os.get env
and then i'm gonna put token now the
reason why it's token here
is because that's the name i put right
here you can actually use any name for
the token doesn't have to be token
you just have to make sure that when
you're getting the environment variable
you use the same name here
so now when you run the code it's just
going to replace
um this right here with your
token now if you're doing this locally
or you're doing in such a way where you
know nobody's ever
else is ever going to see this code you
can actually put your token right in
here
and you don't even have to import os
here but since we're doing it in a
public way we need to make sure that
nobody else sees our token
or else they could get access to our bot
and that's actually it for our basic bot
like i said we're going to add some more
additional features later but let's run
it now and test this out
so click run here
okay look we have logged in as encourage
bot
now let's go to our server you can see
look
before it showed it as logged out but
now it shows it as
logged in so let me
uh let's try this i'll say hello
now you can see that's from from me and
it didn't respond because remember the
special command is actually
dollar sign hello so let's try that and
it works encouragebot just responded
with
hello so our bot works if we do another
command like
hi how are you or not another command
another message
it's not going to respond at all but if
we do the dollar sign hello
then it will respond so we just created
a
basic discord bot that responds to the
command dollar sign hello
and obviously you can make it any
command so if you don't want to respond
to dollar sign hello
you can actually use any command here
and then you can change what it's going
to respond with
now that we have our basic bot working
we'll improve it
like i said it's called encourage bot
for a reason
the bot will respond with a message of
encouragement
whenever someone sends a message
containing a sad or depressing word
we're going to make it so anyone will be
able to add encouraging messages for the
bot to use
and these messages will be stored in a
database
so they will save even after you stop
and start your bot
we're also going to add another thing in
the database
that turns on whether that turns on or
off
whether the bot is is responding to
messages
and an extra feature of encouragement
we're going to do is that the bot is
going to return a random
inspirational quote from an api
when someone types the message dollar
sign inspire
into the chat so let's start with that
last thing i said we're going to start
by adding the dollar sign inspire
feature
i found this api called zenquotes.io
that will return inspirational quotes
now you can use any api
so if you don't want to use zenquotes.io
you can just find a different one
if somehow this isn't working just try
to find a different api
but we're going to use then quotes dot
io and a lot of these principles will
apply to really any api that you're
using
so let's go back to our bot and
we are going to import some new things
to work with this api so what we're
going to do is we're going to import a
couple more python modules
we're going to add a get quote function
and we're going to update our bot
code to call the function so
let's import requests
this request module allows our code to
make an http request
to get data from the api the api returns
json
so we're going to have to import
the json module
because that's going to make it easier
to work with the data that's returned
okay now we're going to add a helper
function it's called get
quote this is a function we can call
to return a quote from the api
so first we're going to use the request
module to request data from the api
url so that's going to go like this the
response we're going to store the
response from the api in a variable
called
response
and so we have to use the request module
like this request.get we're going to
make a get request
to this url now i just had to find this
url by looking at the documentation of
the zinc
quotes api so http
s colon slash slash zen
quotes dot io
slash api slash random it's going to
return
a random quote
okay now we're going to convert
that response into json so we're going
to do
json data
equals json.loadsresponse.txt
so this response.text i just had to look
in the documentation of the api
and found out that the response is going
to have this response.text
that i can i can load into json
so now we have to do something with this
json
we have to get the quote out of it
now this was a lot of trial and error i
had to
print out the json data and try to
figure out
how how to get the exact part of that
json
that i need it so so this is what we
ended up with
quote equals json
data zero
q
now that's going to be the quote q
stands for quote
and it's just something that's part of
the zen quotes api
the the the result that's returned from
this api
is going to have a key called q
with and the value is going to be the
quote so we're going to start with the
quote
but then we want to add after the quote
the author of the quote who said it
so i'm just going to add a plus we're
going to do some string concatenation
here
and i'm going to make it have a space
after the quote and it's going to be a
dash the dash is going to be right
before the person's name
it's just a way to kind of show who's
who's doing the quote
so we'll do another plus here and let's
go back into the json data
and this time instead of the
queue we're going to do a for author
okay so we got our quote in here now
i can return the quote
okay now we have to update our bot so it
uses
this get quote function to get a quote
and then
return the quote as a message to discord
so let me scroll down a little bit here
so now i'm just going to update these
lines here
this was just an example to reach to
respond to the message hello
but that's not what our final bot is
going to do
so i'm going to change this to inspire
and let me just move this over a little
bit so we can see more
of the code so if it if the bot
gets this message inspire we're going to
send a quote so the way we're going to
send a quote
is first adding another line so i'm
going to put quote
equals get quote
so it's going to call the get quote
function and return the quote to here
and now i can just return the quote i
can send
the quote to discord
okay at this point we can run the code
and try it out if it's already running
we're going to stop it
and then run it again
and then we have to wait till it says
it's logged in as encourage bot
that means we can go back to our discord
server
and say hi bot doesn't say anything
let's see if it'll say hello hello
okay that command doesn't work anymore
because we change it let's do
inspire okay we have an
inspirational quote and let's try
inspire a few more times to see if it's
random
there's another one
there's another one so we're getting a
random quote
um for every time we do it so this is
the quote part by failing to prepare you
are preparing to fail
and then we add the the space and then
the dash and then the author benjamin
franklin
okay well that works let's go go back to
our bot code
now we're going to implement the feature
where the bot responds with encouraging
messages
when a user posts a message with a sad
word
so in this this time the user isn't
putting a certain command into discord
to get a result
this time the bot is going to be
checking every word and every message
to see if there's a sad word and if it's
if it notices a sad word it's going to
return an encouraging message so the
first thing we're going to
do is to create a python list that
contains the sad
words that the bot will respond to so
right after the
client variable is created i'm going to
create another one called sad
words and the say our word this is just
going to be a list like i said
oops um there we go
depressed
unhappy now i'm gonna have a list of
words here you can add additional words
um really you can put any words you like
on this list here
oh how about miserable
um and we'll just do one more how about
depressing
okay so we are going to make it so
whenever the bot
sees one of these words in the message
it's going to
respond so what is the bot going to
respond with
well now we're going to add a list of
encouraging messages
that the spot will respond with when it
sees one of those words
so i'm going to make a new variable
called starter
encouragements
now i'll tell you why this is called
starter encouragements
it's because these are the there's going
to be just a few
encouragements that the bot starts with
but users will be able to
add more encouragements later that are
stored in the database
so the start encouragements i'm just
going to do a cheer
up
hang in there
and you are a great
person or maybe it's just another bot so
we'll do
person slash bot
feel free to add any number of
encouragements you like
and remember later a user will be able
to add more encouragements
now we need to update our bot to use the
two lists that we just created
so the first thing we're going to do is
import the random module
because the bot will be choosing
messages randomly
so import random and we'll be using this
later the random module to make it
get the random message so we're going to
update the
on message response here we're going to
add something on
in this on message async function
that's going to check all the messages
to see if they contain a word from the
sad words list
and then if the state word is found the
bot will send a random message of
encouragement
so here's the code for that after we
check to see if it has
starts with inspire then we're going to
check just if it has any other word from
the sad word list
so this is how we're going to do if any
if any wait if
any word in
message for word and sad
words so this just means
it's going to go through every word in
the sad words
and gonna see if any of those words are
in
the message if it sees any of the words
in the sad words in the message
then it's going to await
message dot channel dot send
this is just like this line above here
and what is it going to send it's going
to send
random dot choice it's going to choose a
random
choice from starter encouragements from
that
that list that we created okay we can
test the bot now let's see if there's
something wrong here undefined name
message
okay i got it i got ahead of myself here
actually this uh
message should be uh it's actually
supposed to be message.content
but i switch it to message because since
we're going to be using message.content
a bunch of times
what i want to do actually is
create the message variable right here
message equals
message.content and then anytime we see
message.content we can switch it with
message here
okay let's test the bot now
okay let's go back over here let's see
if the inspire still works
that worked now let's check uh the sad
words i am sad
you're a great person bra person's life
spot
well now i am depressed
hang in there oh that's making me that
is making me feel much better
thanks this encouraging buy is very
encouraging
so it's working it can now respond
whenever it sees
sees a sad message it's going to try to
encourage the person
that put that sad message
so at this point you basically know
enough to create your own bot
but let's keep going because we're going
to add some more advanced features that
i already discussed
now let's make it possible to update the
bot
right from discord a user should be able
to add more encouraging messages for the
bot to use when it detects a sad word
like i mentioned before we're going to
use replete's
built-in database to store user
submitted messages
this database is a key value store
that's built into every rebel
so let's add that to our code now now i
showed you this before this tab
here this the only really the only point
of this tab
is to just show you the commands the
most common commands for the replic
database
and you don't actually need to get them
from here if you already know them you
can just type them in
but let's go to the top of the code and
we're going to
i'll can just insert this so i just
inserted from
repli import db
this allows us to use the replit
database
before we add new commands for the bot
let's add two helper
functions that the first one will be
able to add custom messages to the
database
and the second helper function will be
used to delete messages from the
database
so let's go under the get quote function
this new function is going to be called
update
encouragements
so that's gonna it's gonna update the
encouragements in the database
and it's going to accept an encouraging
message
as an argument
so first it's going to check if
encouragements is a key
in the database so if encouragements
should i do that right encourage mints
is in db.keys
so db.keys just returns a list of the
keys in the database
so if encouragements is already in the
keys
it's going to get those all the key all
the encouragements are already in the
database
encouragements
equals the way to get a value from the
database that's stored under a certain
key is like this db encouragement
okay so we've gotten the encouragement
now we just have to add the new
encouragement to this list
so encouragements
dot append that's going to add them
something new to this list
and we're going to type in the
encouraging message
which is the argument that was passed
into this function
and then after we append the new
encouraging message
to the old encouraging messages we have
to save it again into the database
so db
encouragement
equals
encouragements
else if there's not already
encouragements in the database
then we're going to have to create it so
db encouragements
equals and we're going to put a bracket
here because this is going to be a list
but it's only going to have one message
and the one message
is the encouraging message that was
passed into this function
okay so now let's see what we did wrong
up here
okay that's supposed to be if
encouragements
in db.key not is i just accidentally
typed an
s instead of an n so that's supposed to
be n okay
so now we finish that helper function
let's create a new one which is to
delete an encouraging message so
def delete encouragement
and it's going to take an index
as is an argument
the index of the message to delete
so first we need to get a list of the
messages from the database
so encouragements
equals db
encouragements so we got the list of
encouragements from the database
now we have to check if the length of
encouragements
is more than the index because
the person could pass in an index that's
that's actually
not in that that list
the person could pass an index that's
actually not part of the list
so if the length of encouragement is
more than the index
then we're going to delete d e l is
delete
we're going to delete the encouragements
at that
index and
finally we are going to save
into the database again
equals encouragements
and this can actually be in this if
statement
okay done we can now
add an encouragement and delete an
encouragement
now let's update our bot code to use
these functions
so users in discord can update
encouragements and delete encouragements
right from discord
so let's go down here
so the first thing we're going to do if
you remember
currently it returns a choice from the
starter encouragements
if it sees a sad word but we want to
also be able to return a random we want
the random encouragement to also be able
to come from
the database so let's add some code
to be able to use the starter
encouragements with any encouragement
that has been added to
the database so first of all i'm going
to create a new variable
options equals starter
encouragements okay
so now if there if there's any
encouragements in the data
in the in the database
if encourage mints
in db.keys
then we can we can
add those to the options so options
equals options
plus db
encouragements
okay so now instead of picking from
starter encouragements we're going to
pick from options
of what encouragements to return
now we're going to add some code to add
a new user submitted message to the
database
so it's going to be looking for a new
a new command
so if the message from discord
starts with
the command
new if it starts with the command new
that means it's going to be a new
message to add to the database
so the command that the bot is going to
be looking for is the command dollar
sign new
but then in the same message that you
that the user
puts dollar sign new they're going to
put a space and then they're going to
put the new
encouraging message so we need to break
off
the encouraging message from the the new
command because we don't want to add the
new command to
the database we just want whatever text
comes
after the dollar sign new whatever text
that the user
submits after dollar sign new we want to
add that to the database
so let's do let's get the encouraging
message
and the cursing message going is going
to equal message dot
split we're going to split off the
message from new
so we're going to do dollar sign new
okay so we are now going to get an array
of the message that splits at new
and so we're getting the second element
in the array and that second element of
the array is going to be
the new message now you can see that
we're not just splitting at new we're
splitting at new
space so there's a space after that
because we don't want
the user is going to put dollar sign new
space and then the message
and we don't want to add the space to
the database we just want the message
after the database or after new so we
got the new encouraging message
now we just need to update the
encouragements
with that new encouraging message
then we want to send something back to
the user so they know
that it worked correctly so await
channel or message dot
channel dot send
new encourage couraging
message added
oh yeah that that should be in again i
don't know why i keep doing that
if encouragement's in db.keys
okay now we'll add the ability for a
user to delete
a message so
a new function if message dot starts
with
if it starts with dell or delete that's
what del stands for it starts with
dell we're going to get the list of
messages
encouragements or we're not going to get
the list of messages we're just going to
actually just create an empty list
called encouragements because we're
going to want to return the new list of
encouragements later
so we're going to start it start this
with an empty list
and we're going to check if there's any
encouragements already
so if there's any encouragements already
in db.keys
then we're going to delete one of them
first we have to get the index from the
command
so
so if message that starts with
dollar sign
delete
so if it starts with dell dell that
means delete
then we're going to first create an
empty list uh
incur we're going to create an
encouragement variable as an empty list
that we will add to in a second
if encouragements we're checking if the
encouragements are already in the
database
because if there's no encouragements in
the database then we don't want to try
to delete any of them
so if it's already whoops it's supposed
to if concretions are
in db.keys then
let's get the index from the message
that the user submitted
through discord so we have to get the
index
or we have to split it from from
the here so message dot split
and just like before we're going to it's
going to look very similar
del and
this time adding the space
there is optional let me show you what i
meant
so um before we add a space here
this time we don't necessarily have to
have a space because
we are going to convert it to an integer
so whether there's a space or not it
will still correctly convert
to the integer whatever no they're going
to type in a number the user is going to
have a number after
the command l and it's going to be
converted to an integer in python
now we just need to delete the
encouragement
that's at that index and then finally
we need to get a list of all the
encouragements that
get the the current list after it's been
deleted because we're going to return
that to the users
so they can see the updated list after
it's been deleted
and now we're going to send that back
await
message dot channel dot send
encouragements okay
so the reason why we made an empty list
here is because
if there if there's no encouragement
in the database already it's just going
to return the empty list here
but if there is encouragement in the
database it will get those
encouragements and then
return return those
okay let's test this bot
and then we'll add some a few extra
features
so i'm running the bot again
okay the bots running and we will test
it
so let's test the other features first
we still get an inspiring message now
let's try to add a
new message
you are amazing
okay i just realized i made an error way
up here
database has no attribute key
so um that's supposed to be key
z with an s at the end so let's stop
this again
let's run this again
that's why i'm it's good to test
frequently
to catch these uh these mistakes like
this so let's go back over here
okay now let's try typing this again
again new
you are amazing
new encouraging message added so let's
add another one
new way to go
um that may not make sense depending on
the message that the person
uh put in to get that message but that's
okay new
you are the best
coder in the world
okay now in order to receive get one of
these messages
women we have to have some sad words so
i
am sad hang in there we've already seen
that one
let's just type in stat again way to go
now way to go
that's one of our new messages so
this is one of the original messages the
starter encouragements
but now we've received randomly one of
our new messages
i'm not sad anymore
you are a great person bot i'm depressed
well i guess you have to spell it right
cheer up trying to see another new one
you are amazing that's another new one
that we put in there
okay it now let's see if we can
delete a message so
we should be able to delete a message
with
dell and let's just delete the first one
so i'll just put in zero
and now it's going to return the
messages that are left
now just way to go and you are the best
code in the world it doesn't have
amazing so that one was deleted so that
worked
right now the only way you can see all
the messages
that are all the user submitted messages
is to
delete one it would be nice to be able
to see the user submitted messages
without having to delete one so let's
add some additional
features let's go back over to the bot
so after adding the ability to get a
list of user submitted messages
from right from discord we're going to
add the ability to turn off
and on whether the the bot responds to
sad words
so you will be able to actually update
that right from discord whether it's
going to be
responding or not
so we're going to kind of do all that at
once
first of all we are going to create a
new
key value pair in the database
so right after the starter
encouragements
we're going to check if
responding is in the database yet so
this is going to be a new key in the
database
responding if it's not in the database
db.keys
then we're going to add it and it's
going to default it's going to start off
by being true responding
equals true
and we do need to put a colon right here
and now we only want to respond if this
is
true so down here where it responds to
words
this this whole section right here
is when it's is when it's responding to
the sad word so i'm going to press
tab here because this is all going to be
inside an
if statement if
db we're going to get the value of the
responding key in the database
responding
so if that's true then it will
respond to the sad words if not it won't
respond to the sad words
in a minute we will add the ability to
update this value
so let's go back before we add the
ability to update that value
we're going to add the ability to list
encouraging messages
so if message dot starts with
and you may be able to guess what the
user command is going to be is it's
going to be a list
so if the user com the user types in
list
into discord then
first of all we we're going to get we're
going to make a a
empty list encouragements equals an
empty list because there may not be any
encouragements in the list yet
so we are going to check if
encouragements
is in db.keys with an s
then encouragements we're going to add
them we're going to
set the encouragements in the database
to the encouragements variable db
encouragement
and then we just have to return the
encouragements so await
that message we're going to send the
message to the channel
dot send encouragements
okay now users should be able to get a
list
of the encouragements now we're gonna
add the feature
of changing whether the bot is going to
respond to
sad words or not so
if message dot starts with
responding quotation mark
responding
then we're going to get the value so the
idea is that the user is going to put
responding true
or responding false that's the discord
message that the bot is going to receive
as a command
so if no no value we're going to get the
value that the user typed in
so is it true or false split we're gonna
do just like before responding
and again we're gonna put responding
space because we don't want the space
right after that
so we want
the first element in that array which is
the second the second element of the
array in
index one so we got the value so now
if value dot lower
no matter if they type in lowercase or
uppercase we're going to
convert it to lowercase so if it equals
true then
we're going to make sure that db
responding
equals true
and then let me scroll down a little bit
here we're going to send the message a
message back to discord
await message
dot channel dot send
responding is on
okay we're going to have an else i'm
just going to copy this whole thing
so if value.lower does not equal true
i'll just change this to else
we're actually making it so the person
doesn't actually have to type in false
anything but true will be
assumed to be false so
encouraging the responding is going to
be set to false
and it's going to say responding is off
the code for the bot is complete this is
all we're adding to the bot
we're not quite done though we're not
quite done we're going to test it
and then i'm going to tell you about one
more very important
step so let's try this
let's go to back to our bot oh we have
to run the bot again
okay the bot is running
hey bot i
am sad okay it added that
now let's get a list of our messages
remember since it's stored in the
database
there should still be messages yep see
these are the messages messages we added
before
the last time we ran our bot but since
it's stored in the database they get
stored depend
between times that you've run your your
code
so let's add one i'll put
add nice
i'm just nice
oh i did that wrong it's actually
supposed to be
dude make sure you type in the commands
right
and let's list them again and it shows
nice
now let's delete something delete
index one that should be the middle one
and yep it shows them and we can even
list them again
now let's see if we can change turn off
and on
whether the bot is responding let's conf
confirm that the bot is responding
uh i'm sad nice maybe
it's saying nice because the data is sad
it's hard to tell with this bot
but let's see if we can turn off the
messages so responding
false
if i type in sad and it doesn't say
anything if i
type in depressed it doesn't say
anything
but if i do responding
true
okay let's do say i
am depressed
okay the bot thinks that's pretty nice
now
since we created the responding variable
in the database
it will save whether between times even
if you
shut down your bot and re-run it it will
still save whether it's supposed to be
responding or not okay so
technically our bot is done but you
don't want to stop
now because if i
close my tab the bot will just stop
running and then it's not going to work
if i close my browser the bot is going
to stop running it's not going to work
there is a workaround replit will
continue
running a web server even after the tab
is closed
now this is not a web server but we can
create one to run at the same time as
this
but even a web server will only run for
up to an hour
without any use oh here's the replic
docs about the the web servers
see it says once deployed the server
will continue to run in the background
even after you close the browser tab the
server will stay awake and active
until an hour after its last request
after which it will enter a sleeping
stage
so even if you um have a web
web server running it will eventually
stop running after an
hour after it's last request so if
nobody's using the discord bot it'll
just stop working
however there's a way to make the bot
continually get
requests so it never shuts down
so actually rip rebel has announced that
in the future they will offer a paid
plan that allows code to run
continuously
no matter what it will just never enter
the sleeping stage
but they don't offer that quite yet it's
coming very soon maybe it'll be
available by the time you see this video
but until that is implemented
there is another way to keep your bot
running longer than an
hour and this method even works with the
free tier of replit
so to keep this spot running
continuously we're going to use another
free service called
uptime robot uptime robot can be set to
ping the bot's web server on replit
every five minutes with constant pings
the bot will never enter the sleeping
stage
and will just keep running so we have
two more things to do to make sure bot
is working as we want
to make sure it's working running
continuously we're going to create a web
server in replit
and set up uptime robot to continuously
ping
the web server okay creating the web
server
is simpler than you may think to do it
we're going to create a new file so i'm
going to go to files and click the add
file button
and this is just going to be called keep
alive dot
pi because the whole purpose of the web
server
is to keep um keep everything alive
okay i'm just going to paste in the code
from the web server here
it's pretty simple like i said and it's
not
it's not really specifically important
for the bot
it's just a thing that we should do in
replica to make it keep going
so i will have a link to the text of
this web server right in the description
here so you can just copy and paste it
also
but you can see it's not that long so in
this code we're going to
import flask and we're going to use
flask as the web server
and it's going to return hello i'm alive
to anyone who visits the server
the server will run on a separate thread
from our bot the server is going to
run on a separate thread from robot so
they can both be running at the same
time
but the rest of this is not really
relevant to our bot
we just need the bot to run this web
server
so let's go back into main.pi
and then at the top
we're going to have to import it so from
keep alive import
keep alive and if you just go back over
here
that's this it's importing this which is
this is what runs our
web server here so from it's going to
import the web server and then we're
going to go all the way to the bottom
and right before the client runs we're
going to call
keep alive and this will
run our web server so if i stop the bot
and re-run the bot
it's something different is going to
happen because of the because of the web
server
okay you can see a new window opened
right up here
and this is our web server running and
see that's how it says hello i'm alive
that's from our web server code where it
says return hello i'm alive so whenever
you go to the server
it says hello i'm alive now the
important thing here
is this url so this url was created
and this is the url that we are going to
ping
from uptime robot so i'm going to
copy this url right here and then we're
going to use it in the next section
so now we need to set up uptime robot
so the first step is to create a free
account
and then get logged in
okay once you're logged into uptime
robot just click
add new monitor for the monitor type
https and the friendly name you can name
this anything we're going to just put
bot and then for the url this is where
you paste in the url that you copied all
over from repel
reply and the monitoring interval will
just leave this the same as
every five minutes and then create
monitor and then create monitor again
monitor created so i can close this and
we should be able to see it right here
here it is this is now going to ping our
bot
every five minutes so
at this point it's going to be continual
it'll
continue continue to run even after we
close our tab
and even after an hour even if there's
no
activity in discord this bot will just
run continuously
let's just try closing the tab really
quick i'm just going to copy this
url close the tab uh let's see if we can
just
open the tab back up on here
and you can see it's still running it's
still running and this right here
it could mean it is going to say
something like this every time it's
pinged
i don't know if that's from the ping or
not or if it's just from reloading
but we are now done now the bot will run
continuously
so people can always interact with it on
replit
it's time for a bonus section you
already know how to set up a python bot
and run it continuously from replit now
i'm going to show you how to set up
another discord bot
to work with web hooks we are going to
connect
the bot to github so that the bot will
post a message to your server
whenever a certain github repository is
updated
and for this github bot you don't even
need to code anything
or host it anywhere let me show you how
it works
okay to add this github bot we'll go to
our server
and then we'll go to the server settings
here
and then we'll click integrations and
then
there's web hooks create web webhook
and instead of calling it captain hook
i'm going to name it
i'll name it github okay
and it will put it in the general
channel and then i'll just copy
the webhook url
okay i'll make sure to save
okay now i'm going to go over to the
github repo that i want to connect
with this bot so i'm going to use the
freecodecamp.org github repo
and then i'll go to settings
and then on the side here it says web
hooks
okay now i'm going to click add webhook
and then i'm just going to paste in the
url that i copied from discord
now here's an important part you can't
just use the url you also have to add
something i'm going to add slash
github at the end of the url
and then for the content type i'll
change it to application slash json
and then i'll scroll down and for what
event should trigger the web hook
i'm going to do send me everything
depending on what you're trying to do
you may want to do just the push event
or select individual events
but i'm going to do everything so i'll
add the web hook
and now i can go back right over to
my discord channel if i wait
we should start to see some events
happening
on the the from the freco camp github
repo
and let me go and just try to make an
event happen i'll just
unstar and start the repo
and it worked we just got a message from
the github bot
new star added
so now we've connected our bot to github
through web hooks
and with the github bot will post a
message
whenever anything happens on the github
repo
you can create bots to work with a lot
of other external services with web
hooks
okay you've reached the end of this
tutorial now you're prepared to go out
and
code your own discord bot